[Musique]
merci
étranger étranger merci étranger
nous sommes humains d'abord et tu vois l'
humanité d'abord tu ne vois pas qu'ils
viennent illégalement tu ne
dis pas attends une minute tu ne devrais pas être
ici
ce n'est pas notre  premier instinct humain
merci
[Musique]
en ce moment je suis éteint
je ne peux pas je n'irai pas dans la rivière
parce que personne ne veut y entrer
à cause de tout ça
tu sais je ne peux pas leur montrer à quel point
notre site est beau  Est-ce que ça te semble beau,
c'est une zone de guerre, il a demandé au gouverneur, le
gouverneur du Texas
d'aménager une jolie petite scène ici pour
la faire ressembler à une zone de guerre, vous savez,
mais vous regardez de l'autre côté,
c'est magnifique et c'est comme ça
côté utilisé pour regarder ici naturel
beau
solo